[Aplausos]
estamos prontos para o tour já fui uma
pessoa extremamente bom humanitária e
com deságio de mudar o mundo sempre foi
uma característica muito forte pode
querer fazer mais e melhor
era algo que os transportava em mim em
favor dos conflitos do mundo ea china
são 11 e embaixo da chapa falar certas
experiências e situações de pobreza e
souza passaram a linha sofrimento pra
mim é algo que não consegui ficar sem
fazer nada criança promotor e fazer algo
de diferente
também sempre fui completamente
apaixonada um destino das crianças na
escola energia sempre rota famosas por
serem de tudo o que o estudo apresenta
em mim transmitiu sempre algo muito
especial e que o crime está inserido na
câmara cria poderia fazer a diferença
através de uma instituição num de
voluntariado do socorro vai ficar muito
melhor e vender e alugar para contar a
minha história tem que dizer que antes
disso aconteceu uma grande oportunidade
da minha vida
o fez mudar completamente a minha forma
de pensar e de atuar e reagir para os
problemas do dia a dia e que foi ele
também quem não usar toda essa energia
da estação de tristeza para algo que
possa ser benéfica para outras pessoas e
que minhas costas ultrapassar o meio dia
a dia com esta facilidade de entrar o
meu primeiro então é isso
talvez com a língua no tempo é num nó
festa no real dos casos na feira do gol
estava com o spartak consumir e vias
embalagens de crude maia a tenda da cruz
montada em toda aquela presença em forma
de pergunta que eu gostava e então disse
sim então eu disse aqui que gastar e
misty may que quer estar envolvido quer
fazer voluntariado quer fazer a
diferença
quero aprender a ser excluída tripularam
boazinhas e realmente mudar a vida de
alguém através dessa forma como essa o
meu percurso de entrada com uma área de
vos dizer que
não foi muito fácil e isso significa que
na altura não muita gente pode não
gostaram muito da idéia é tentar pagar o
chamado custo alto desde 1987 quando há
muito tempo não confirme sua instalando
o alto do restelo onde quer pra mim
entrada na câmara mas ele não conseguir
minha vaga como sempre fui uma pessoa
com bastante determinação com um
objetivo muito bem traçado e
praticamente um ano de ponte entre a
baiana quando seu reino a recrutar e
curioso este ano faço 20 anos com padre
cruz machico teló a fazer serviço
posso entrar na malha porque dei a minha
vida tá falando o que prevê projeto e
servir um dogma trabalhar em equipa o
que fazer 5 4 antes o que realmente
fazer a diferença na vida de uma pessoa
por 15 jet ski no satisfazendo diário
devo dizer também que ser voluntário é
dar o tempo jorge pinheiro mas também
tira faz com que tenhamos que estar
prontos
mesmo querendo ou não um em várias
situação estar de serviço para fazer
prevenção de 20 sejam elas fim de semana
e trata semanalmente sociedade muito
grande
o observatório porque realmente fazer
alguns sacrifícios disse que às vezes as
pessoas não não percebem um voluntário
que a vitória o sacrifício que faz por
alguns por paixão que aqui que eu quero
que eu gosto que eu quero fã de que é
quem é voluntário e quem se dedicar a
uma causa que sabe exatamente essa
mensagem
então foi a entrada da personagem este
curso que comecei a correr mas a nunca
fui uma pessoa que era produzir que x
mas que queria saber mais queria
aprender mais cria fazer mais formação
diferenciada não achava que aquela
formação do bairro pinheiro dólar era
suficiente para ser um bom ciclista ser
um tripulante
então fui à procura de outras formações
ea procura das organizaçons pudesse dar
realmente aquele que nunca há muito não
tinha então algumas organizações foram
extremamente importante para mim
nomeadamente onu cujo fundamento é um
grupo que na altura criei e trouxe
algumas pessoas fantásticas que o
acompanhavam no estudo
em 2006 na cruz maia em outras
organizações foi extremamente importante
como o segundo pólo sinnott foi
conseguir a promoção foi como sair com o
gado
creio nem de fazer esta parte
humanitária às pessoas que é fazer as
coisas porque mudar a vida de alguém num
elas precisam da cor e que aprenderam
como ir e como essa ter uma sensação
ainda muito maior em de 3 saber mas
creio e psicose crise mudou para muito
mundo e nós vamos mudar o mundo não é
fácil mas cada gota realmente podemos
realmente fazer à empresa eu a minha
passagem no investimento passou por toda
a jogada mas hoje o problema que eu ia
pra mim reclamar suporto é uma
organização é uma organização que faz
formação na área do trauma ou seja faz é
formação mais diferenciado a técnica em
enfermagem max as conquistas que querem
fazer promoção mais diferenciada que
nunca tinha se mudado na madeira porque
tem açúcar fora porque tinham que
despender muito dinheiro e tempo para o
fazer e nós realmente trouxemos essas
formações sendo construído com essas
pessoas que me acompanhavam então e
seguindo o nosso percurso formativo não
estava no meu ao ju formação de
socorrista fazer sensação de alertar
consciências
até que um dia uma mãe parou
completamente porque me mandou
completamente o dia 17 de junho de 2012
estava em casa um dia normal como todos
os outros
era um domingo de manhã e os clubes
transformador meu acho que minha força e
minha determinação de mudar e alertar e
ensinar como fazer a mulher informará
também já teve o joelho pessoas
completamente conscientes e alertadas
para a prevenção e para tudo aquilo que
pode acontecer neste também a nossa
filha sem ninguém se aperceber uma bola
daquelas bocha salt tunas
vamos ter em casa as vans que saiba que
eu sou daquelas máquinas tinha uma filha
mais velha que é margarida tem ao todo
200 m ano novo
chegou na bola e colocou na boca
o fato de ela colocar aquela bola na
boca forma repentina ex-piloto o objeto
e ou espirar book e ficou presa na
nigéria o que faz com que naquele
momento ela não conseguir frear ou seja
o que acontece eu como pai como se
conhecendo e amando isso a minha atuação
foi pensar como os clubes de passarem
directamente àquele que seria fazer
aquele que o poderia fazer que era fazer
uma estátua está obstrução era dar umas
pancadas nas costas para tentar
desobstruir que o objeto era fazer umas
condições não dá do domingo para tentar
explodir e que o objeto formalmente
repentina e quase sem pensar em mais
nada
todos os prefeitos quando vimos que a
situação era grave que nós não estávamos
a conseguir resolver
fizemos o trânsito alerta ao 112 e então
aí com uns aí me aperceber da
dificuldade e de gravidade da situação
para saber em que vivenciar todo este
cenário com a minha mulher e minha filha
mais velha a presenciar
queremos fazer tudo e mais alguma coisa
para tentar o xodó e realmente reverter
aquela situação não estávamos a
conseguir a sensação de impotência ea
sensação de queda segundo o que está a
passar a cada segundo que mais difícil
conseguir o cemitério é fazer uma coisa
que é o suporte básico de vida reanimar
porque sabia que se eu não estava a
conseguir desobstruir e vieri de que o
objeto e dinheiro no mundo inteiro
afirmou davies lógica dela era aquele
que eu sabia que estava longe da minha
campanha eu tinha com o primeiro tenho
que fazer esporte nosso desejo
até que chegou o socorro chegasse o
cenário é bastante difícil disse ao dn
genial voltar ao passado
são seis anos que passou uma expansão
importante na nossa cabeça o que
acontece naquele momento quando isso
acontece parece que o nosso
nos times do nosso corpo naquele momento
vi terme por breves segundos foi o
estudo a que o formulário e imaginamos o
que aqui está acontecendo e voltarmos à
realidade precisa mexer está conselho
tenha que o chile tem que trabalhar tem
que fazer algo para que não se agrave
é claro que é extremamente difícil no
edifício que
do que se pensa como é que outro passo
uma situação destas
então foi aí que eu propósito dia
mariana foi cuidados intensivos onde uma
noite onde ea cabo faux e na manhã
seguinte mantendo se a oxidação
houve algumas lacunas que aconteceram no
percurso centros como chegar e até lá e
possui algumas coisas correram mal
nós pessoas que estavam dentro do maio
coletadas começando algumas dessas
lacunas que acontecem e deixou bastante
triste bastante revoltado e que levou
muitos ai que a parte pediátrica é sendo
chamado no tendão de aquiles do socorro
pré hospitalar porque há sempre nova
formação protestante diferenciado pré
hospitalar por todas as pessoas conhecem
quando vêm os corpo uma criança e nem
senso familiar os filhos seus netos
grandes e tudo se torna mais difícil e
isso muito foi bastante difícil
entretanto esta situação passou e pensar
no momento a seguir nos dias seguintes a
prova abaixo a nossa faz a praias todas
as chances possíveis e imaginários que
nós podemos e imaginando que possam
ajudar a salvar a mãe desaparecem e é a
minha força e minha determinação em
querer mudar o mundo e ensinar os outros
produtos e não sabia se continuava a
fazer aquilo que eu queria continuar
então eu pensava pra mim não faz sentido
eu sinto um gordo dos 20 que eles é
vender um produto para emagrecer
zagueiro porque eu passava aquela
informação aos outros vizinhos não
voltou contigo porque quero voltar com
ele
acho que logo logo um de hoje uma semana
não saiu do zero hoje mudar
completamente a minha opinião eles não
não sou assim o isso não é a minha forma
de pensar
estranha forma de atuar e isso muito
terminado em alcançar meus objetivos e
quer mudar o mundo e tem uma força
interior que vocês nem imaginam mãe foi
na evocando a usar a energia minha força
e vou alertar os outros para a
importância de saber fazer esporte
bastilha obstruir as vias aéreas pensar
mais na formação da área pediátrica
pensava na província na importância
sobre fazer este espaço como uma
situação em que não sabia fazer você não
conseguir resolver
não porque não tentar e não seria bom
não veio para resolver nem todas as
situações que consegue mas aquelas
pessoas que não sabem fazer nada que
tivesse uma situação destas não seria
muito pior
muitas vezes e conhecem bem certa forma
o que está a acontecer num contexto onde
estava por exemplo de convivência eu
presenciei tudo mas nem tantas vezes
tivesse acontecido quando ela estava com
os avós uma creche a outra situação em
que eu não pudesse ter estado lá pra mim
seria muito pior no inpi a não conseguir
imaginar o que pensei a número 12
então é isso aí uma coisa que é a
associação de emergência o que se chama
de emergência já ligado à ami à cruz
malha obter lhe és a outras organizações
foi o fato de juntar e culminar de
conhecimentos de pessoas que o
acompanhava que são uma equipa
fantástica e que os estão sempre
presentes só em equipe e nós fechamos
fizeram com que nós criação desta
associação mandar emergência com o
objetivo mais de 600 mas que está em
suporte básico de vida da informação e
sim se basear na área da pediatria e
então a partir de uma delas disse quando
nós criamos algo que nos ajuda a nós
próprios
ajudamos os outros e fazemos com maior
paixão possível imaginar e com gosto e
que nós que estamos fazendo aqui que nós
queremos realmente fazer aquele que nos
apaixona que nós certa forma viemos ao
mundo pra fazer que aquilo que considero
é isso que faz toda a diferença
então poderemos vencer taiwan é um
crescimento gradual um crescimento
sustentado na fase inicial foi
complicado
puxando um ficando conhecidos geralmente
nacionalmente e é muito bom ver esses
retornos reconhecimento partes das
pessoas do trabalho que nós fazemos
diariamente para cuidar de outras
escolas
juntos é diferenciado com formações
específicas fase de implementação dos
programas diego fica do outro lado
estamos fazendo informação do básico
rede de suporte básico de vida seus
assuntos em escolas no trabalho
realizado ao longo destes 56 anos que
nós existimos
por isso manteremos em primeiro por
cento muito e nunca
eu nunca vou deixar de osório por isso o
objetivo para este problema e por
alertar a consciência das outras pessoas
da importância deste tema
ora é mariana teve uma passagem curta na
nossa vida
ela tá no braço forte como sempre teve
nove meses que teve presente conosco era
uma criança extremamente feliz com os
olhos grandes ou seja nem ter no entanto
alegre e nós pensamos sentido que existe
porque isso nos acontece a mim que sou
uma pessoa que considere ter valor para
a sociedade que faz voluntariado
consideram bons só porque mesmo vai
acontecer uma coisa dessas porque que o
clero dos outros farão da formação na
área pediátrica porque também a
contratação quase igual à que o ensinou
a fazer é quase impossível de imaginar
mas eu procurei nem vale a pena
o que posso dizer é que tudo que nos
acontece
se vou manter uma razão da condição aqui
com uma condição o fato de mariana
pesado pior love possa ter o conselho só
dar mais força para poder continuar
o primeiro tem proposta muito importante
que eu não acredito em consciência
acredita em deus ciência
isso quer dizer que tem uma razão c&a
certeza ter uma razão para ter
acontecido e o que tiro toda esta
situação aconteceu foi pensem que é pior
que seja o cenário do pior que seja a
nossa situação assim paulo portas vão
poder tirar do bom dessa situação e vão
ter revertê-los ela em algo de bom para
vocês e para os outros sempre isso é
fundamental 1ª a uma frase pra mim é
muito importante que é o do ouro verde
socorrer como essa no verde sobre os
correios em uma frase extremamente
importante para mim outra vez uma
organização que era o tal bilhete que
faz com que nós não sabemos fazer as
coisas não vão poder ajudar os outros
desde que faça a informação precisa
botar se disso percebi a importância de
passar tempo com as vossas famílias que
os vossos filhos que é que dá o sentido
da vida
obrigado
[Aplausos]